-I'm so happy to see you.
I can't wait to get
into this movie
'cause, gosh,
you're phenomenal in it.
And I don't know how much
I can say about it,
but, whatever,
let's get into it.
First of all, was it last night
you just were at MoMA?
You got honored.
-It was last night, yes.
I'm still processing
the whole thing.
It was really emotional,
really intense.
I'm very grateful.
-I mean, look at how gorgeous,
by the way, last night
at this film benefit.
Look at that, come on.
Gorgeous.
[ Cheers and applause ]
For all the work
that you've done
and then you get to see
kind of a retrospective.
But you're just so young.
I mean, it's interesting
you get this.
-I mean, I feel young.
And I was kind of...really
grateful but overwhelmed
and asking myself, "Why me?"
-Well, you've done great things,
amazing stuff.
And it was a great group of
people as well last night.
-Yeah. Very grateful to all of
the people that came to support.
-Yeah, it's wild.
-People that I admire a lot
and that I love.
-I know you're based
out of Madrid, right?
-Yeah.
-But you lived in New York
for a while when you first
started, right? Is that true?
-I came here to study English
when I was around 19.
And I spent a couple of years
but always going back and forth.
And, yeah, it was a dream also
to be able to work
in this industry.
You know, I've been very lucky
to be able to work in
a lot of different countries
in Europe and also here.
-Yeah.
-Very lucky to have that.
-And now here you are
back in New York.
You're getting honored
in New York City.
-If somebody would have told me
that when I was 19,
I would be like, "No way."
-I wanted to ask you because I
know -- I've seen clips
of you and your husband being
pulled on stage at concerts.
I don't know if it was
the Garden, maybe,
that's what I'm thinking of
or maybe it was L.A.
But U2?
-It happened with U2.
It happened with Prince.
-People just like to pull you
on stage and sing to you.
-Apparently, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, do you know
that's going to happen
in advance or no?
-With Bono, yes. He told us.
And he said, "Come on.
You cannot say no."
We're very close friends
with him and the whole band.
But with Prince,
it was a surprise.
And I was very excited
to be there.
But at the same time
I could not wait
to get out of the sta--
the stage.
It was terrifying.
-Because you're --
Were you standing next to him?
-Because he was expecting us --
expecting us to dance
and maybe even sing
and it was terrifying.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Because you have nothing
planned.
You're like, "What do I do?"
-No, exactly.
-Like, "I'm here to see you."
-Exactly.
-I once remember doing a bit
with Bono and the band.
He wanted me to come up
and do this thing,
but he forgot to bring me up.
-No, he cannot do that to you!
-No, so I'm standing there --
-Next tour.
-I'm like, "Hey, we rehearsed
this whole thing."
And he just totally forgot
all about me.
I go, "Hey, buddy!"
Like, "I thought we had a bit."
-Next tour, you have to be there
for sure.
And he made us wear wigs
and all kinds of things.
-Yes, that's right!
That's what I saw.
Yeah, there was, like, a boa.
-But we loved it.
We love him so much.
-Oh, yeah.
But I mean, you got to be
friends with Prince, right,
after that, or...?
-Actually, you know,
I kind of was like friends
with him at the beginning.
It was weird because,
first of all,
I said, "How should I call you?
Symbol? Prince?"
Like, anything is weird.
-Oh, yeah, he was a symbol
at one point.
Yeah, at point,
yeah, you're right.
-But he was really kind to me
and all my friends and family.
And he used to throw these
parties at his house
that I'm sure you know about.
-I've read about, yeah.
-And you probably have been
in some of them.
-Unfortunately, no.
He forgot about me as well.
[ Laughter ]
It happens, yeah.
But I heard these parties
start at like 1:00
in the morning and go all night.
-Those parties were the parties.
I mean, I'm not very much
a party person.
But when I went to those,
I would stay there until 5:00
because the amazing things
that were happening
in that living room.
You could see Stevie Wonder
singing with Alicia Keys.
And Farrell dancing with Diddy
and with Justin Timberlake.
And I mean -- and then Prince
would join and play for a while
and then he would
put the pajamas
and come back
and say good night
and he would go to bed
and leave all of us there.
-He would come down in pajamas
and go, "I'm going to bed"?
-Once he did that --
came back with his pajamas
and say good night.
-He said, "Lock up.
I'm going to sleep"?
-No, he would leave everybody
at his house, partying.
And he would go
or go into the studio
at that time of the night.
But he was so kind and so sweet.
And there is not one day
that I don't miss him.
-Aww.
I want to talk to you about your
new movie, "Parallel Mothers."
You are so good in this.
-Thank you.
-In fact, you -- It debuted at
Venice Film Festival.
You got this --
You won this amazing award.
This is the -- Is it the Volpi?
-The Volpi, yes.
-The Volpi Cup.
-Yes.
-Can you explain what that is?
-Well, that's the acting prize
in Venice.
-In Venice.
-And it was such a big deal
for me because the first time
I went to the festival,
it was like 30 years ago, and I
went there with my first film.
And then to win with a movie
with Pedro
was really, really magical.
Yeah.
-Yeah. That's a wild thing.
Congratulations on this.
I want to talk more about
the film when we come back.
More with Penelope Cruz
after the break.